holy cow
people it is november 19th
2020 i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message
and i am caffeinated i chugged the glass
of water and i'm ready to roll today
there is so much going on yet uh today
yesterday i did three stories that just
sort of uh
shined a light on just general
progressive lunacy across the board but
today there is like
just so many things happening at once i
i hope and assume that some of you
watched at least part of this rudy
giuliani
sydney powell uh press conference that
they just had
where they're beginning to lay out the
case for what they are now calling
massive election fraud just because
they're saying it doesn't mean it's true
but they are beginning to lay out the
case we're going to show you some video
and i'll tell you a bit about what they
said if you didn't see it but it's
seemingly starting to come together
and ultimately either at this point
these guys are lying and at the same
time taking down
their careers and probably personal
lives and any prospects for a
decent future on this earth or
they've really got something here so for
all of the people that for the last you
know roughly 15 16 days since the
election
have been saying well you got to have
some proof you got to have some proof of
course that is
true and correct uh well now it seems
like they're starting to leak some of
that out there was some really
interesting stuff that they were talking
about so we'll get to that
we're also going to talk about i'm going
to play some video
of a california republican
who had some interesting things to say
about gavin newsom having dinner and he
had an interesting flip on it's a guy by
the name of tom mcclintock who i had
never heard of he's a
representative in northern cali but he
had a nice flip on what
gavin newsom has been up to locking us
down while he's having thousand dollar
plate dinners
and then two stories that are really
kind of one story in illinois
uh they are going to be pushing uh this
concept to quote embrace and promote
progressive views in schools
not good not good and directly linked to
that
megyn kelly is taking her two kids out
of new york city schools
because of some of the stuff that they
were trying to brainwash them so we're
going to link those
those two together before i do anything
else though real quick i just saw this
tweet and i
felt i felt that this exchange that i'm
going to read to you right now we're
going to show you is just like
this is peak 2020. this is
everything that 2020 is about so i don't
know who this woman is it doesn't matter
who he
who she is don't tweet at her just let
it be but i have to read this exchange
to you
so this is a woman her twitter's at in
touch for now
and she tweets uh she's in uh southern
australia
so she tweets at hey sa police news
that's southern australia police news
for the sake of my stupid husband who's
doing a karen from brighton moan can you
please broadcast very specific
information
about walking the dog the south
australian police
then respond hi andrea you cannot leave
the house
to walk the dog or to exercise she then
follows up in a further tree where she
thanks them for
telling her that and saying uh you know
basically says stay safe but i just
thought it was like the perfect exchange
of 2020. we have people literally
tweeting at police stations
as to whether their stupid husband her
words not mine
are allowed to walk the freaking dog
this is where we're at this is where
we're at it's just bananas
but instead of bananas you know what's
good people what's good bananas
second thoughts of the game it's this
year's new favorite party game
that's sure to be the hit of your next
game night after the election results
are made official if that ever happens
it'll be more necessary than ever to
connect with family and friends over
some light-hearted fun
david and i host thanksgiving all the
time and we're going to do it this year
despite what's going on and we're
looking forward
to playing second thoughts after a
delicious turkey dinner
the play of the game calls for each team
to quickly create a list of words for
their opponents to decipher leading to
hilarious but puzzlement people love
when i say
puzzlement and laughter simply put it's
a classic
word guessing game with a unique twist
that allows players to personalize the
content with their voluminous sense of
word smithery
or just their witty and warped
imaginations each round of second
thoughts is a hilarious high-speed
attempt to stump the other team
both teams create a list of five things
using the letters revealed from the
color dice
be witty and wise but don't take too
long because time is not on your side
the amount of time it takes you to
create the list
is exactly how much time your opponents
get to guess them this game gets really
fun
after a couple glasses of wine or
whiskey or whatever your beverage of
choice is
second thoughts the quick thinking verse
fast talking party game
and for the month of november the game
will be on sale at a special price so be
sure to get yours today at second
thoughts the game dot com
that's second thoughts the game dot com
or at your local target store
and now back to me okay people so for
the last hour
it's been streaming all over the place
but you're not going to see much of it
on mainstream news
again the reality war i'm always talking
about rudy giuliani and sydney powell
they're trump's lawyers they have been
making the case now you can say it's all
nonsense you can say where's the proof
but they are now starting to slowly leak
things out and and they're making
massive allegations
they are talking about massive illegal
allegations uh let's go to this video of
sydney powell this is just in the last
15 minutes or
or so and well i don't want to put any
words in her mouth so let's take it away
we're allowed to rig their elections
this
is stunning heartbreaking
infuriating and the most unpatriotic
acts i can even imagine
for people in this country to have
participated in
in any way shape or form and i want the
american public to know
right now that we will not be
intimidated
american patriots are fed up with the
corruption from the local level
to the highest level of our government
and we are going to take this country
back we are not going to be intimidated
we are not going to back down
we are going to clean this mess up now
president trump won by a landslide we
are going to prove it
and we are going to reclaim the united
states of america for the
people who vote for freedom
so if this is this is pretty big stuff
okay now
she later goes on and there is other
video of this we were scrambling because
it just happened right before we started
uh there's other video where she talks
about how the dominion software
actually has a function a drag and drop
function this is these are her words
where you can actually drag votes from
one candidate
give it to another candidate or outright
throw it away like throw it in your
desktop
trash can okay now if they have proof of
this and she's saying
that they do then and she's also saying
that thousands and thousands of
votes were changed by this well then we
really got something okay now i am not
sitting here dave rubin
on november 19th 2020 is not sitting
here
saying this is true just because they
say it but
let's try it this way if you're sidney
powell you're a respected lawyer for for
many decades rudy giuliani former
mayor of new york city got us through 9
11. former attorney general former
lawyer
in in a presidential administration
reagan
took down the mafia in new york city
these are people who know how to build a
case these are
people who know how to fight the system
sydney powell was michael flynn's
lawyer now that doesn't mean they're
they're true they're what they're saying
is true it doesn't mean they have some
airtight case i'm
literally not sitting here saying that
what i am saying is just at a personal
level like if they're just
saying crazy stuff if they're just
making it up and saying crazy stuff even
though they have sworn affidavits
they're saying that they have people on
the inside
and they're putting together the case
everyone wants them to just drop all the
info now
but that's not you know if any of you
have ever been in any sort of legal
proceedings whether you're in a divorce
or a a civil case or a criminal case you
don't just drop everything that every
the second you get info you don't just
drop it and
share it with everybody right you build
a case so you can drop the bomb or
release the kraken as they say now i'm
not even saying there is a kraken but
what they are saying now is
hey we know thousands of votes were
switched we know how it happened within
the electronic voting systems
she's also calling it a i think she said
an international conspiracy because
votes were counted
in venezuela like like a whole bunch of
stuff but the point is
at the personal level putting aside the
political level for a moment
if they're just making it up like then
then sydney powell and rudy giuliani are
legitimately insane right like if
they're going to destroy their
professional lives their careers
but not just that their personal lives
their ability to get jobs in the future
their ability to be
part of respectful society it's like if
they're willing to do that
out of what misguided loyalty to trump
or something like that like
then they're they're actually nuts and
should probably be examined by
psychological professionals i suspect
it's not that it doesn't mean that
everything they're saying is exactly
right and this is what they're gonna
have to prove but
but we're in a really really interesting
spot right now and again
watch i dare you i don't like having to
ask people to do this but watch a little
bit of mainstream media tonight watch
watch cbs abc's abc
cbs abc and nbc watch them tonight watch
cnn tonight
i never tell anyone to do that i'm sorry
but if you're watching tonight like
see how they report on this see if they
show you the quotes
about the drag and drop about talking
about massive fraud like
whether the people at abc cbs nbc cnn et
cetera whether they think it's true or
not like they're supposed to report on
the news this is a news event now
if it's a news event of people that are
fraudulent liars well then you report on
that
but when they ignore something well then
people start going well wait a minute
maybe something is here
that leaves people like me going all
right i guess i gotta i guess i gotta
talk about these things uh hey guys
before we get to the other stories
though i want to talk
about glint card you know i've been
talking about glen card for the last
week or so it really is a
super cool way of buying and selling
gold
and then actually being able to use it
not just saying i've got some gold i
can't do anything with it oh it went up
it went down
whatever else you can actually use it by
using your own
glint pay card the glint card which
allows you to buy
products on amazon or at starbucks or
wherever you go
you can use it just like a debit card
and you can choose within the app
whether you want to actually spend
gold or you want to spend your own cash
and then you can
buy and sell within the app as well and
it's all super easy they take really low
fees and all that good stuff
and it's just an interesting way of
getting a little more control
over your finances so you guys should
totally check it out and the glint card
is issued by sutton bank which is a
member of fdic
pursuant to license from mastercard
international it's free to sign up so go
to glintpay.com
ruben for more info and to start
purchasing gold today that's
glintpay.com
ruben to get your gold today and now
back to me
so we'll go from glint to mcclintock
did that work i felt like that was sort
of a transition there that was something
like that
so you guys all know the story of the
last couple days gavin newsom our
ridiculous governor here in california
who was the mayor of san francisco who
ruined san francisco but then became
governor
and he he wants rules for thee but not
for me
he's up at french laundry which is in
wine country
he's at a dinner with 12 people it's
indoors big chandeliers carpets
thousand bucks a plate i don't begrudge
him any of that
other than he's telling us not to do
that and telling us that we can't have
people over for thanksgiving
well uh representative tom mcclintock
who is a rare republican
here in california uh he was on the the
floor and he had this to say
about gavin and i thought it was i
thought it was a nice twist on things so
take a look
mr speaker i rise this morning in
defense of governor gavin newsom
who recently defied his own idiotic
coveted edicts
as he partied at one of the few
restaurants that's not yet been forced
out of business
i defend him because he was doing what
we once
all did in a free society make our own
decisions over what risks were willing
to run
and what precautions were willing to
take according to our own circumstances
to protect our own health yes covet is a
nasty bug
and a quarter of a million americans
have died while having it
but this isn't the bubonic plague
the cdc's best estimate is that if
you're under 49
your chance for surviving covet if you
get it
is 99.92
percent even if you're over 70 you have
a 94.6
rate of recovery 40 percent who get it
don't even know they have it
and yet we've allowed our officials to
ruin our quality of life over it
destroying countless businesses throwing
tens of millions into unemployment
robbing our children of their educations
and shredding our most
cherished rights as americans tom
mcclintock
i don't live in your district but i like
you and i like the way you took the flip
on that thing
because he's saying in essence yes
people we have to make some choices in
our lives
and we can't stay locked down forever
while our leaders decide to not
uh obey the very laws that they're
pushing on us the laws the edicts the
all of the all of the nonsense that
every day they tell us some new thing
can't happen and it's
or new some new thing must be obeyed
and it's like man how can you run a
business how can you live a functional
life
like this so i like this tom mcclintock
and you know one of the things
that everyone in california it's so
interesting one of the things that i
find about california more than anything
else if you ask
anyone in california especially san
francisco and l.a you ask them well
how's it going here
everybody is like man education sucks
the road sucks there's homelessness
everywhere the drug use
the taxes are high it's hard for
businesses we're locked down but
like and then and then you go why do you
live here and they go with the weather
the weather is nice and the weather is
nice by the way it's it basically
the last week here it's been 78 to 82
and just beautiful
nice and crisp in the morning i took a
long walk with the dog this morning
and i was with my buddy and i was like
this is why you pay the high taxes and
you deal with all the nonsense
but that at some point becomes secondary
to all of the crazy stuff
right and we are a one party state
pretty much so tom mcclintock you're
doing something right you want to run
for governor dude because that that
would be
that would be pretty great we do need
some people i know more and more people
keep thinking i'm running for governor
but i like this
i like this you know like the idea i
gotta go to the
state capitol and deal with the
lobbyists and the morons i i just can't
do it
uh but speaking of uh education these
last two stories that i'm going to sort
of combine into one story i think
they're sort of perfect and they come
out of you're not going to believe it
guys
totally democrat-run states illinois
and new york and specifically uh chicago
and new york city uh so illinois schools
are now proposing a rule that would
force teachers to
promise that they would in quote embrace
and promote progressive views so let's
get some quotes on this this is from the
daily wire
the rule published in the illinois
register on september 11th
titled culturally responsive teaching
and leading standards for all illinois
educators
requires that educators embrace and
encourage progressive viewpoints and
perspectives
that leverage asset thinking towards
traditionally marginalized populations
it further states to address systems of
oppression
a culturally responsive teacher and
leader will be aware of the effects of
power and privilege
and the need for social advocacy and
social action
to better empower diverse students and
communities
okay i could go on and on and again you
can read the full
piece at the daily wire but i think you
get where i'm going with this
they are trying as if they haven't done
it enough as if the cultural
and intellectual rot of the left
of social justice of critical race
theory
of oppress oppressor and the oppressed
as if all of this
hasn't wrought enough damage on our
systems and our way of thinking and led
us to this
insane polarized place that we're in
right now
well now they want it in public schools
not just
at places of higher education which
mostly is about getting stoned because i
don't think anyone's getting any real
higher education at colleges anymore
this is seriously dangerous stuff the
effects of
power and privilege and the need for
social advocacy and social action to
better empower diverse students
and communities meaning in in short it
is judge
us on our skin color judge us on our
ethnicity
judge us on our gender and our sexuality
all of the stuff that is the reverse of
what the united states was set up to do
and now they are going to they're going
to infect this
into the system so they will actually
create a system
of systemic racism and systemic
privilege
and the rest of it uh i should mention
that you know one of the things when
people say to me dave how do you say
you're liberal anymore and i barely do
say that it's not it's not that i am not
classically liberal as i have discussed
for years and years and years but in
effect
if you're a classical liberal you're an
old-school jfk liberal and
you believe any of the things that i
laid out in my book or i talk about here
like in effect you're
you're a conservative of today like it
just it just is reality i don't mind if
someone calls me a conservative i'm
trying to conserve america i'm trying to
conserve liberalism
but one of the things that i say often
is people say well what makes you a
liberal and i could you know okay i'm
for gay marriage
and i'm against the death penalty and
i'm begrudgingly pro-choice
and one of the other ones that i always
say is i feel that there is some level
of state education
public education that is valuable i'm
not sure how much longer i can say that
one because as the state gets taken over
by these terrible ideas which by the way
trump was really fighting by getting
crt critical race theory out of the
institutions
if he's gone and and these ideas get
back in there it's like how can i
possibly defend that the state should
have to educate anyone because in
essence
they're not educating anyone they're
just indoctrinating people
uh but speaking of that very thing uh
megyn kelly who as you guys know she's
she's a friend of mine and has been on
the show a few times and i'm actually
taping her podcast tomorrow so i think
that'll air
probably in a day or two after that she
is actually now
taking her kids out of new york schools
and let's go to the quotes from her it's
really quite something
uh this is from her from her podcast
where she announced this
it's out of control on so many levels
and after years of resisting it we're
going to leave the city
we pulled our boys from their their
school and our daughter is going to be
leaving hers soon
too the schools have always been far
left which doesn't align with my own
ideology
but i didn't really care most of my
friends are liberals it's fine i come
from democrats as a family
i'm not offended at all by the ideology
and i lean
center left on some things but they've
gone around the bend i mean they have
gone off the deep end
this summer in the wake of george floyd
they circulated amongst the diversity
group which includes white parents like
us there are people who want to be
allies and stay attuned to what we do
an article and afterward they
recirculated it
and wanted every member of the faculty
to read it so what you need to
understand here
and if you want if you want the full
context of all of that you should listen
to megyn kelly's podcast
but in essence megan is saying she's
pretty much on the right
right she's a she's a conservative but
much like some of the things that i just
laid out
gay marriage i think she's against the
death penalty i'm not totally sure on
that one i think she's a little more
open when it comes to abortion
i don't want to speak totally for her
but you you get it that
this is not megyn kelly whether you like
her or not and by the way some of my
audience that's that's more on the trump
side really doesn't like her
and that's just fine by the way um
that this is not an extremist by any
estimation this is someone who comes
from a family of democrats who
says right here that she has some
center-left views this is someone who
obviously
should be able to educate her kids and
send her kids to a school that that is
open and pluralistic and all of those
things
but in essence what she's saying is they
have gone
too far they have just gone too far they
are injecting racism and everything
they're teaching white kids
to feel inherently guilty by the color
of their skin
that's called racism and she's getting
her kids out so
i combine that with the story from
illinois that i just
went over because i think good people
are going to start selecting out i think
over the next year
we're going to see more of more and more
of this good people are just going to
start selecting out of the system and
out of the system i mean they're going
to take their kids out of public school
they're going to do more homeschooling
or
charter schools or school choice by the
way charter schools and school choice
things that democrats are against
as they send their kids usually to
charter schools and private schools much
like gavin newsom does of course
the governor here and just like
elizabeth warren does in massachusetts
um elizabeth warren who also pretended
to be native americans so that she could
uh you know get a job so you know that
that's sort of what these
what these people are up but i think
more and more people are going to select
out they'll select out of public schools
i think they're going to select
out of social media i think they're
going to select out of jobs at
traditional companies as more and more
companies become
infected with these ideas and by the way
i don't think that's necessarily a bad
thing i think the the thing that i
am probably most proud of in my life is
that by going independent by going solo
building studios
building technology like we did with
locals to make sure i'd be okay without
big tech
it's not a perfect system but we're
getting pretty damn close
to employ people to treat my guys well
so they work hard for me so we can grow
the business so i can treat them better
and we can keep
doing that wonderful exchange that
capitalism is all about
well in some ways i've selected out now
i do this on youtube obviously we gotta
get stuff on apple podcast spotify and
everywhere else
so there's no perfect system but i think
we have opportunities now to rethink the
world and think about what you really
want to do
do you want to send your kids to places
where they'll be brainwashed do you want
to work at big companies that are
that hold views that are antithetical to
your own
you got an opportunity to figure it out
so that is today's silver lining
by the way guys part two of my interview
with north korean defector yonmi park
who's also a friend of mine and just an
absolutely inspirational person who is
now worried about america
after living in north korea and china
and she tells us why
part two of our interview just went up
this morning part one's already there
the full episode is already up at
reubenreport.com
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel over here and
we'll be back tomorrow we're gonna do
tomorrow is gonna be i think all q a so
if you want to submit a question
go to reubenreport.com i'll be posting
in the morning and you can submit a
question in the comments and we'll do an
uncensored ask me anything q
a have a great day everybody
you